Here's another challenging problem that uses the Pythagorean theorem. This time
we'll have a ladder that 17 feet long, that leans against a building. The
distance from the bottom of the ladder to the building is 7 feet less than the
distance from the top of the ladder to the ground. What you need to find is the
distance from the top of the ladder to the base of the building. Now, we'll
walk through this problem just like one before. First, I want you to tell me
what are the expressions for each of these sides? Try to label the parts of the
diagram that you know, and then when you think that you have numbers or
expressions for each of these. Enter them in the corresponding box. If you use
a variable, make sure that you use the variable x. Good luck here.